vamos al inciso se escriben los primeros
cuatro términos distintos de cero de la
serie de mclovin para a la equis usa la
serie de mclaren para la equis para
escribir un polinomio de taylor de
tercer grado para que dé x igual a la x
por fx alrededor de x igual a 0 y bueno
acá abajo tengo a fx los vamos a
utilizar en un momento pero de nuevo te
digo si todos estos términos como seres
de maclaurin o series de taylor te
parecen desconocidos no es familiar para
ti entonces observa los vídeos y haz los
ejercicios en la canaca de mil sobre
estos temas independientemente de que
ahorita de un pequeño repaso por aquí y
para eso vamos a hablar acerca de una
serie de marketing de fx así que
imagínate que tú te tomas a una función
efe de x entonces la serie de mclaren
para esta función
fx será aproximadamente igual porque
bueno solamente vamos a hacer algunos
términos aproximadamente igual a efe de
0 a efe de 0 esto por x elevado a la 0 y
a esto lo dividimos entre 0 factorial
bien ya esto le sumamos f prima de 0 que
multiplica a x elevado a la primera
potencia esto dividido entre 1 factorial
ya esto le sumamos f
mi prima de 0 ok por x elevado al
cuadrado muy bien estoy dividido entre 2
factorial creo que ya ves el patrón de
todo esto y a esto le sumamos f tri
prima en la tercera derivada de f con
respecto a x lo voy a escribir así f
prima prima prima
esto que multiplica a x elevado al cubo
y esto dividido entre 3 factorial y
bueno así nos vamos a seguir y seguir y
seguir
y bueno justo por eso estoy poniendo que
es aproximadamente porque aquí solamente
estoy poniendo los cuatro primeros
términos y bueno claro cero factorial y
x elevado a cero
estos dos es lo mismo que uno entonces
simplemente me queda
efe de cero y aquí uno factorial también
es 1 entonces solamente me queda f prima
de 0 por equis y así nos podemos seguir
entonces esto es aproximado y ahora
quiero que hagamos exactamente lo mismo
pero para que a la x nuestra función fx
va a ser a la x y entonces si aplicamos
esto para la x nos va a quedar
aproximadamente aproximadamente y
primero tengo
efe de 0 y bueno elevado a la 0 es muy
fácil es lo mismo que uno entonces me
quedaría 1
y después tengo efe prima evaluado en 0
pero la x es una función muy curiosa
vamos a recordarlo aquí sí efe x es
igual a la x entonces cuánto vale f
prima de x bueno lo que pasa es algo muy
padre
efe prima de x es lo mismo que esa misma
función para esta función a la x es una
de las cosas mágicas que le pasan a esta
función a la x que la pendiente de la
recta tangente en cualquier punto de
esta función es exactamente igual al
valor que nos da de evaluar a x en esa
función y por lo tanto stevie prima de x
f prima prima de x va a ser exactamente
igual que a a la x de nuevo así que te
tomes cuantas derivadas quieras vas a
seguir obteniendo ea la x esta es una de
las cosas especiales que tiene la
función
entonces me va a quedar la primera
derivada evaluada en 0 bueno eso es a la
0 que ya vimos que es 1 por x entre 1
eso es simplemente x ya esto le voy a
sumar y después tengo la segunda
derivada de la x evaluada en cero bueno
eso ya vimos que es simplemente 1-1 por
equis cuadrada es x cuadrada entre 2
factorial bueno eso es x cuadrada esto
dividido entre 2 porque 2 factorial es
lo mismo que 2 por 1 y después tengo la
tercera derivada de la x evaluada en 0
lo cual es 1 por x cúbica entre 3
factorial eso es lo mismo que x kubica
está dividido entre 3 factorial y
podemos escribir aquí 3 factorial o 3
por 2 por 1 que es lo mismo que 6 y
bueno aquí le voy a poner más y sigue
y sigue ahora estos son los primeros
cuatro términos distintos de cero de
nuestra serie de mclaren para la equis
así que esto es la primera parte de este
inciso de lujo pero después dice usa la
serie de mclaren para la equis esto que
tenemos aquí para escribir un polinomio
de taylor de tercer grado para gdx igual
a la equis fx alrededor de x igual a
cero entonces voy a reescribir la
función f de x original que es esta que
tengo aquí voy a escribir los primeros
términos y después pensaremos en cómo
multiplicar estos dos polinomios y ya
con eso al multiplicarlo tendremos que
encontrar todos los términos que no
tengan un exponente mayor a tercer grado
porque es justo lo que nos piden un
polinomio de taylor para esta head
de tercer grado entonces vamos a
escribir que fx 7x es aproximadamente y
bueno voy a copiar los primeros términos
de esta serie que tengo aquí me quedaría
x menos tres medios de x cuadrada más 3x
cúbica menos porque tengo más menos más
menos y voy a poner que esta serie sigue
y sigue y siguen porque estoy seguro de
que con esto es suficiente y por qué
estoy tan seguro de que con esto es
suficiente bueno es que si escribimos el
polinomio de taylor de tercer grado al
multiplicar estos dos vamos a involucrar
términos de grado mayor si seguimos
apuntando términos ene efe de equis y
eso nos va a dar un polinomio mayor de
tercer grado y eso no es lo que queremos
así que vamos a hacerlo lo que quiero es
tomarme y a la equis que multiplica a
de x esto es lo que quiero y bueno esto
va a ser aproximadamente y vamos a
multiplicar este polinomio infinito por
este otro polinomio infinito lo cual en
un principio es un poco intimidante pero
también podemos multiplicar cada uno de
estos términos por cada uno de estos
términos es decir cuando multiplicamos
dos polinomios esencialmente es lo que
haces es tomarte la propiedad
distributiva en repetidas ocasiones
entonces si tomas este de aquí y lo
multiplicas por este y después por este
y después por este y después por este
observa que estamos distribuyendo a este
por cada uno de los términos que tenemos
acá arriba y ahora ten cuidado sólo nos
vamos a fijar en los términos que nos
interesan es decir los que tienen un
grado menor o igual a 3 bien pues
empecemos x por 1
es lo mismo que x después me quedan x
por x es
x cuadrada después tengo x x x cuadrada
entre 2 bueno eso es lo mismo que x
cúbica entre 2 y aquí voy a parar porque
observa si multiplicas x x x pública
entre 6 eso me va a dar algo de cuarto
grado y no es lo que queremos verdad
queremos un polinomio de tercer grado
entonces hasta ahorita tengo x mas x
cuadrada más x kubica entre 2 y ahora
vamos a distribuir la multiplicación de
este que tengo aquí por bueno por los
términos que tengo acá arriba entonces
se multiplicó este por 1 me va a quedar
menos 3 medios de x cuadrada lo voy a
poner acá abajo menos 3 medios de x
cuadrada y bueno esto para que pueda
sumar fácilmente al finalizar esta
multiplicación y después tengo menos
tres medios de x cuadrada por x eso es
lo mismo que menos
tres medios de x cúbica y de nuevo voy a
parar ahí porque voy a parar ahí porque
se multiplicó estos dos me va a dar algo
de cuarto grado y recuerda eso no es lo
que queremos voy a bajar un poco la
pantalla para seguir y terminar este
problema y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
tomarme a este que tengo aquí y
multiplicarlo por los términos que tengo
acá arriba y primero tengo 3 x cúbica
que multiplica a 1 bueno eso es lo mismo
que 3x cúbica lo voy a poner acá abajo
con todas las equis cúbicas y después
tengo 3x kubica por equis cuidado eso me
va a dar algo de cuarto grado y no es lo
que queremos y después me daría algo de
quinto grado de sexto grado y en
definitiva no es lo que queremos
entonces basta hasta aquí vamos a sumar
estos términos que tengo aquí estas son
todas las piezas que nos van a dar el
resultado que estamos buscando este
polinomio de taylor de tercer grado para
de x así que vamos a sumar cada uno de
estos que tengo aquí para ver qué
obtengo de resultado final vamos a sumar
estos y voy a obtener a x y después
tengo x cuadrada menos 3 medios de x
cuadrada bueno eso es menos un medio de
x cuadrada muy bien y después tengo x
kubica entre 2 menos tres medios de x
cúbica bueno esto es lo mismo que menos
uno un medio menos un entero y un medio
es lo mismo que menos uno más 3x kubica
es lo mismo que 2x cúbica y ya está
esta es mi respuesta entonces podemos
decir que a la x que multiplica a efe de
x esto va a ser aproximadamente porque
bueno solamente me voy a tomar los
términos de grado menor o igual a 3 y me
va a quedar x
- 1 medium de x cuadrada y a esto le
sumamos 2x cúbica bueno esta es una
pequeña intuición de cómo multiplicar un
polinomio infinito por otro con la
restricción de obtener uno de tercer
grado y tal vez todo esto parezca un
poco enredado pero puedes ver que usamos
un poco de cálculo y usamos un montón de
álgebra usamos más álgebra que lo que
usamos de cálculo y justo así fue como
obtuvimos este que es nuestro resultado
este de aquí solo distribuyendo una
multiplicación de un polinomio por un
polinomio aunque hayan sido polinomios
de un número infinito de eternos al
principio pensé oh esto está muy difícil
cómo puedo multiplicar polinomios
infinitos pero la clave es que solo
teníamos que preocuparnos por este
polinomio de tercer grado